good afternoon
my name is Jared Cohen the president of
Carnegie Mellon it's my great pleasure
to welcome you to this 2010 Dixon Prize
in science ceremony when we will be
presented to David Terrell the Dixon
Prize for science David is the Ross
McCollum william h Corcoran professor of
chemistry and chemical engineering at
Caltech this is an important event for
Carnegie Mellon and for Pittsburgh every
year and it's one that we look forward
to a chance to celebrate great
scientists as well as the great science
and happens here at Carnegie Mellon and
we look forward to this every year but I
have to say that this year we
particularly important because in fact
David charelle is one of us in a very
real way he served as an assistant
professor in our chemistry department
from nineteen seventy eight to nineteen
eighty four he was very successful here
in fact he was awarded the melon College
of Sciences Julian ashkan teaching award
while he was here that's an award given
for unusual devotion to undergraduate
teaching which is a particularly sweet
award I think for someone with such a
great researcher as well to receive he's
also been connected to Carnegie Mellon
periodically over the last several years
as a member of the advisory board for
our department of chemistry service that
we greatly appreciate and thank you for
there are other ways though that he is
of us if not still one of us one of the
things that we admire about his work is
some interdisciplinary it is David works
easily in all the time
the boundaries of chemistry biology
material science something that we value
highly review as a key Carnegie Mellon
virtue and characteristic in addition
he's very keen on the impact of his work
he does things because they're
interesting but he takes them to the
point where they could be applied and in
fact and we're proud of the fact that
I'm sure he is too that there are
biomedical devices out in the
marketplace today that he created in
honoring the outstanding scientist that
we do with the fiction prize for science
we're also honoring the scientific
traditions that exists in this city and
that very much was the motivation of the
donors the people who made this prize
possible they were dr. Joseph Dixon a
physician here in Pittsburgh and his
wife Agnes Fisher Dixon who created this
prize in 1970 it's been 40 years by the
way they don't know and created the
Dixon Prize for science which Carnegie
Mellon awards but they also created a
Dixon prize for medicine that the
University of Pittsburgh awards and in
that way they sought to honor the two
great research universities in
Pittsburgh as well and indeed they've
done that I want to note and thank boy
real who's an attorney and attorneys was
connected to the Dixons for many years
for his help and connection to the
University of his prize in his wife
Virginia I don't know if they made it to
the to this event today but they've in
constant and faithful participants in
the past and I thank them for that I
want to thank also guy Barry well known
to you as professor emeritus of
chemistry and all the members of the
Dixon prize selection committee for
their service and finally I want to
thank Chris fetish esky who nominated
David Chris as you know is the JC Warner
university professor of Natural Sciences
that like to call Chrissa to give a
better introduction
David Ravell Chris the good afternoon
it's a really great pleasure and honor
to say a few words about Dave Tyrrell
who this has turned said one of us and I
put here a kind of a summary very
condensed of what David has been doing
during last couple years or maybe tens
of years if I they say but they've
graduated from MIT and then he moved the
University of Massachusetts in fact an
unusual way without any postdoctoral
fellowship he came to CMU in 1978 and
stayed for six years and then it was a
big loss to CMU but in fact I should not
complain much because because they've
left I could be hired otherwise no way
to replace Dave in any way so after
additional 14 years at UMass they've
moved to Caltech work he served as a
chair of chemical and chemical
engineering the division for over 10
years and as dirt sets in the William
Porter and professor of chemistry and
chemical engineering so the first award
was indeed Julius asking a word from
Carnegie Mellon and the most recent
obviously not the last also from a
Carnegie Mellon Dixon price and I
highlighted a couple of them from
american chemical society polymer
chemistry wart and also top scholar
award which really is one of the most
important in organic chemistry in fact
nearly all field of chemistry and Davis
one of the very handful people who are
members of both national academy of
engineering and national academy of
science
in addition to another prestigious
societies and he also holds honoris
causa degree from the University of
Eindhoven and in addition of serving as
a advisory board member of sure in fact
the chemistry department at CMU he also
carries many other advisory committee
membership in the top universities so we
and they first up myself later we are
just really interested in in polymers of
plastic spreading and most general way
and the plastics are so important
because of lightweight but probably than
these easy processing conditions and
very often they are serving as
commodities but also more and more as
high specialties so some enabling
happiness technologies in electronics in
fact the 21st century's becoming center
of polymeric drugs which target special
devices and highly selective is some opt
electronic devices specialty at helix in
my knowledge however although we have a
hundreds or maybe thousands of monomers
one can always look at biology and this
is what happened when they've moved from
from CMU to university of massachusetts
you look at biology in a different way
not really these diversity in red but
more complexity and complexities
amazingly it not on thousands of
monomers by the fact that only five
nucleic acid bases and 20 amino acids so
this is really something that is unusual
and of course in a very ingenious way
they thought how we can combine them
together how one can combine this
complexity of biology which really
evolving opinions appears to something
so complex as
only sells in factually before but
really even ourselves and even our
thinking and framing and this all relies
on five complete as it faces and 20
amino acids at the same time chemists in
last maybe hundred years or so develop
enormous amount of different materials
very useful materials relying on the
ready thousands of monomers so another
question is how we can combine them
together and once I empower can see how
it can make more precisely polymers is
in some control to live in precision
polymerization but on the other side
also can we expand this limited number
of 20 amino acids to something much
larger and this I would say it's a
little jalapeño in the material science
or by all related polymers as well and
they did that in a very ingenious way
using not 20 but 50 additional
non-canonical amino acids you will talk
about it because they include something
like the active groups maybe as ido
acetylene sometimes chlorinated
structures and dance event conductive
polymers based on Caiaphas and then
albums but of course it is not that easy
to incorporate them when it's still
totally lean back he programmed genetic
code and this is what they was doing
doing last twenty central years really
incorporating this more and more
diversified amino acids in order to
benefit the material science they could
have a various special properties where
the surface property sometimes
biomechanical properties and that would
be telling about us today but I think
that in a quest of this holiday the men
of course participants but i think that
real Percival is de vida so we'll hear
from him in couple minutes but
who make mo he said announcement about
the strengths David would you join Chris
and me up here at the pony me bet your
stockbroker David Tyrell on behalf of
carnegie mellon university i'm pleased
to present to you to 2010 fixing prize
of science for your outstanding
contributions to science and his
representation and Rec representative of
this award and presents you with the
medallion and the check congratulations
with explode your election
I'd like to begin of course with thanks
first to president phone for verifying
worse for hosting this event the Dixon
prize of course is a wonderful honor for
anyone it has been a very distinguished
award over the years anyone would be
flattered to be on the list of Dixon
Prize winners and of course the sex
almost better significance for reasons
that president Colin articulated very
nicely Jane and I had a wonderful six
years in Pittsburgh we hold the
university and its faculty and students
in the highest possible regard and to be
recognized by such a roof and by a good
friends it takes on various special
significance so I would again like to
thank President corn thank Chris were
putting together the nomination and I
thank the selection committee Tiberius's
chair and all of you for coming to
today's lecture on the practical side I
also know that such a mess require a lot
of work and Victoria Bush minor has been
will host us for me put together a
complex schedule we spent three days
actually enjoy Pittsburgh again and
things couldn't have been done any
better it's been a wonderful three days
we're very glad to be back in Pittsburgh
so the work that I would like to tell
you about for the next 40 minutes
concerns an approach to macromolecular
chemistry that Chris described in brief
terms just a few minutes ago and the key
idea is that we use artificial genes to
direct the synthesis of artificial
proteins and protein like macro
molecules in cells and so although the
lecture will take 40 minutes the whole
story is a non-single slide and so guy
Barry warned me that he might fall
asleep before the end of the lecture if
it stood with me till the end of this
slide
so as Chris mentioned we begin by
designing sequences of amino acids
either natural ones or non natural ones
that we believe will give us interesting
macromolecules sometimes we're
interested in their chemistry sometimes
the physics sometimes their biology
sometimes their materials behavior are
the same concepts is not from structural
biology and in part from polymer
chemistry and physics once we've decided
on what we would like to make the code
that sequence of amino acids is a
complementary DNA sequence that means we
design an artificial gene or we redesign
a natural one we then have to make that
DNA which is a very straightforward
process now in fact one can often order
full length jeans from biochemical
supply houses and they often work and
through that protein sequence into the
macromolecules is primary interest to us
and in order to do that we use
recombinant DNA methodology that's now
very standard in with us we'll take a
circular DNA on a bacterial cell will
cut it over the restriction enzyme will
put the artificial DNA
that is our recombinant DNA which we
introduced into the bacterial cell those
cells enroll in class or fermenter under
conditions where they'll make the
macromolecule for us and for somebody
who comes from a polymer chemistry
backgrounds as I do this approach has
some important and unique advantages
it's the only way one can essentially
absolute control of the molecular
architecture that is the sequence and
stereochemistry of the change that we
make side of the slide a comparison of a
polymer that can be made either by
chemical polymerization or by gene
expression this is probably who panic
acid which can be made by rear opening
polymerization of the anhydride if one
makes it that way and puts that product
into a mass spectrometer which measures
the length of the chains and gives us a
plot to the number of molecules versus
there we see all the different chain
length varies that characterize any
chemical polymerization process we
always have competing initiation
propagation and termination steps on the
other hand if you want to make a poly
glutamic acid that's a well-defined
molecular species and the United
selected our way to be 8,000 you can
build an artificial gene that encodes
called the glutamic acid and go through
the process on a previous slide when you
put that product into a mass
spectrometer that's what you've seen a
single molecular ion at the program to
molecular weight if you'd like to detain
James TV twice as long a man G Flex's
all three Congress is long and so on and
so the first take home message may be
surprising maybe not depending on your
patient is that you don't lose the
fidelity of protein biosynthesis because
we're making an artificial protein we
see the same level of control here that
one sees in the synthesis of natural
proteins and nucleic acids we also they
access the multiplying folded structures
at the secondary structural level and
hired us so we can begin to control the
three-dimensional arrangement of protein
assemblies and materials we have access
to functional sequences derived from
natural proteins so we can begin to
build biological information into
macromolecular materials we have with
our they've all fares when we don't get
them quite right the first time that
surprise this we didn't anticipate this
at the outset is that this way of
thinking about macromolecular chemistry
would lead us to some new approaches to
biological problems so that's the good
news and that's what drew us into the
field in the first place but there's
also some bad news here for a polymer
chemist and it's just pointed out this
is the fact that proteins are made
essentially from 20 amino acids now 20
amino acids are enough to do catalysis
to do molecular recognition to support
all known forms of life but it's not
enough to be interesting polymer
chemistry and so much of our effort for
the last 10 years has been devoted to
diversifying this set of monomer a
building blocks for the construction of
proteins in cells now we refer to this
process as reinterpreting the genetic
code and I think that's a fair
description at what's going on here
because the conventional
is that we go in aside from DNA to RNA
to protein and then the genetic code
will tell once the messenger RNA is the
made in itself what the sequence of the
protein has to be so the cell is
interpreting the program's influences
their cognate amino acids what we will
do is under conditions where we're
making the protein in the cell is this
look in your code on TV so the gravity G
code on delivering an accolade is pray
it will deliver an analog matheny with
different chemical and physical
properties so we're doing proton
reassignment in the cellar if we're
going to reassign codons we have to
understand how there are signs in the
first place there are two key steps
involved in co does the edori sedation
staff in which the amino acid is
activated by a simple face through
reaction with a PB and attached to the
three prime end of its transfer RNA this
is the most stringent step in the
process everything that comes further
downstream is more permissive than
aminoacylation and if you had a minute
to think about that statement I think
you wouldn't find it surprising the
right is all the parts
receive masses to the end of the growing
chain has to accommodate all 20 of the
natural mean Alexis so it can't be
terribly selected the substations on the
other hand are adapted one by one to the
individual amino acids and their highly
selective with respect to recognition of
the amino acid side chain the second set
which we can intervene in the process of
the decoding set we're pros at 80 dogs
tear up to the liver video answer at the
ribosome we've worked on that step and
I'd be glad to talk with you about it
after the election if you'd like but
what I'd like to focus on for the next
few minutes is it consequences of any
control of even race elation activity of
the cell we spent the last ten years
inventing new amino acids and synthesis
to activate them and by doing that we've
been able to introduce the new monomers
that Chris showed on his slide a few
minutes ago now since as the president
was so kind to say I am part of the
Carnegie Mellon family I don't mind
telling you I am very proud of this
slide she has permissive as it turned
out to be the chemistry
much easier than I anticipated at the
outset the way the amino acids are
organized either they're showing as any
laws of the natural Ruby license so
across the top row we have seven finding
animals that means they'll be recognized
by the final TRX imitations put on to
methanol trnas and delivered in response
to the thymine codes these are losing
their odds and so on the color code
shows what you have to do in order to
get the amino acids to go into proteins
making sense is essential in black you
essentially don't have to do anything at
all you just soak the amino answers into
the cell the wild-type says it tastes
won't activate it and we'll put it into
the protein in response for example two
methylene kodos now if we have lots of
Messiah meal in the set no store owners
will be decoded statistically but when
you complete a methylated from the cell
you can decode over any photos as one of
these glasses for example as there's a
whole album aah a mini Alexis that we'll
talk about in a few minutes if they need
is to be shown in blue it's also
activated by the wild-type Center taste
but very slowly and so we have to
express extra genetic copies of the
synthetase in the side if it's shown in
here or shall we it requires a mutant
since it takes and i'll show you how we
do the surgery on the synthesis to
enable activation of these kinds of
amino acids the other thing that I'd
like you to notice is the range of new
chemistry
in this way natural proteins don't have
carbon-carbon double bonds they don't
have direct bonds they don't have exist
they don't have flurry they don't have
serrated edge that I have ketones or a
substituted aryl groups shown here so as
I mentioned we spent a long time
probably ten years developing the
methodology needed to these amino acids
and colors and eventually we face up to
the kind of question we all face in our
research programs so what why should
anyone care that we have a new set of
amino acids that can be used to make
proteins and what I'd like to do is to
show you in the next few minutes for
examples of why one might care these are
four areas in which we're exploiting
this chemistry to do things that we hope
are either scientifically valuable or
perhaps technologically and ultimately
commercially done the movie side of the
slide refer to the first program and
i'll tell you about initially designing
new proteins for use in surgery and
regenerative medicine and in particular
trying to understand how wounds heal and
how wound healing can be facilitated by
artificial protein design we've
developed methods for analyzing protein
synthesis in cells tissues and whole
animals we have a protein evolution
program where we evolve proteins so that
they can use this new set of amino acids
or in some cases
prefer the city 70 and then I'll finish
you a very short story talking about our
protein modification work where we have
a modified interferon beta in a clinical
trial for the treatment of multiple
sclerosis now they talk will be divided
into four short stories the first two
were wrong for the last two and I'll
warn you while we're known to the next
story in cases drifted off when it's
time to refocus and then involve
anything important so the first story is
a work on materials for surgery and
regenerative medicine these are
materials that are referred to as
artificial extracellular matrix proteins
or ECM proteins and the objective is to
try to restructure tissue as it heals
after surgery it may be simple surgery
it may be something much more ambitious
for one has implanted cells for
therapeutic substances of one kind or
another but they've always have to heal
after surgery we're interested in
controlling both the physical properties
and the interactions of these 13 with
surrounding cells and tissues and we do
this in the simplest possible way we
recruit domains from natural ECM
proteins each of which does part of the
job and we combine them into multi
domain multi functional proteins that we
hope will do the whole job that needs to
be done so for example in the projects
that are going to tell you about
directed toward surgery and the cornea
we're interested in soft tissue
engineering and we need material
properties that match those of the
corneal tissue for that purpose we
recruit domains from the natural ECM
protein ambassador the last things are
made up a large part of just three of
the essence very important and glycine
and so we put together an artificial
gene that encodes long sequences of
those three amino acids we're combining
those sequences with seven binding
domains that are derived from another
ECM protein called fibronectin in
particular this are binding domains that
we're going to use is exactly what I'll
show you containing their own bone rgd
sequence which is marketed for
integrative sectors on the corneal
epithelial cell surface and so what we'd
like to be able to do here is to implant
a kind of contact lens into the corneal
tissue and then to allow the corneal
epithelium to heal rapidly after
implantation and so we need to get into
the code biological information that
encourages that rapid closure of the
corneal epithelium so when we've combed
that combination of sequences into a
long artificial gene and if you
encounter both substrates here you can
see this is quite a lot of protein has
about 40,000 molecular weight or so and
then there's one more feature that we
need to encode and that's the capacity
to undergo chemical cross-linking
between protein chains because of the
world
the cornea and these proteins are
soluble proteins so we need to cross
link them there are several ways in
which we can do that but a particularly
interesting and useful way is to do it
photochemically by incorporating or
non-natural amino acid parecido fennel
abdomen we do this by encoding federer
me in a sequence and then we allow a
zero phenylalanine and phenylalanine to
compete for those code uppers and this
is actually an important feature of the
design because it allows us to make a
whole family of related sequences from a
single artificial gene one of the
standard ideas from early molecular
biology was one gene one polypeptide
that's a longer trip with this case we
make one gene it makes a lot of
messenger RNA itself and then it be
decoded in place depending on how much
is the artificial amino acid we begin
and that will allow assists
approximately materials either very
tightly if we have lots of the
photosensitivity nuances in there or
very loosely if we put in only a little
bit of the cross-linker but before we
can do that we have to face up to the
fact that the natural enzymatic
machinery of the cell won't use parent a
zero phenylalanine the reason for that
became apparent when this crystal
structure was published of the federal
now the no trna synthetase with federal
rebound at the active site the system
face is shown in green and yellow and
then federal round
in purple you might imagine that if we
tried to incorporate three nitrogen
atoms at the 4-position of phenylalanine
we would run into trouble when these
residues is the back wall of the
substrate binding pocket so we did the
simplest thing one could imagine we took
off the side chain by site-directed
mutagenesis converted that residue to a
glycine over the whole of the back and
then we get a synthetase that activates
as it will feed very nicely in fact it
activates is it a fee faster than the
wild-type sim petition activates
phenylalanine itself this allows us to
make a protein in greater quantities we
can cast it into films or it's a lens
and then we can photo cross-linked it we
can watch the disappearance of the
exhibit in the infrared spectrum and we
can see that in about 30 seconds we get
complete cross-linking this event allows
us to mold the structure that we're
interested in with plenty of time taken
to do that and then to do the photo
cross-linking photo curing of that
implantable legs well then put it into
oral saltwater and pull it apart on the
tensile tester and that then allows us
to determine the mechanical properties
to see if they're appropriate for soft
tissue engineering as you would imagine
as we put in more and more of these head
replacing anywhere
thirty to fifty percent to the
phenylalanine the slope of the
stress-strain curve increases indicating
whether modulus effectively the
stiffness of the material is increasing
we get moduli in the range of the mega
Pascal this is about like a soft rubber
band and it's perfectly appropriate for
engineering of corneal tissue the real
test of performance of such objects
though is to implant them in animal
models this is done in rabbits in
collaboration with a group at UC San
Francisco danceworks directs the final
surgery group there these surgeries were
done by Marcia Chun what Marcia did here
was to open the three millimeter opening
in the corneal epithelium this is a
little bit like what would be done in
lasik surgery it makes a surgery the
surgeon votans the epithelium and uses a
laser to burn away part of the point of
stromal tissue we don't have to remove
any tissue in this surgery this surgery
by the way is called the corneal always
surgery it's not going to practice
because there is no material that
performs as a satisfactory way so Marcia
removes the epithelium over three
millimeters spot she's been abreast
Laurel lands on the hoods on toxin in at
the edge and drops on a little bit of
flourishing so you can see where the
protein is exposed that's the green area
that's the end
right there that's into the lens right
there immediately after surgery in two
days it looks like that and after one
week we get with integration of the lens
into the corneal tissue that's the
result that we were after it's
encouraging but of course in order to be
useful these kinds of implants when
Apple asks are very long time and
they're now i'm doing a longer term
implantation experiments to see if they
do now there may be wondering i hope you
are did that rgv see once really make
any difference what would've happened if
you'd put in the protein with an hour
since we don't know we never did that
control we probably won't do that
painful in animal studies but we can
look carefully in in vitro models of
wound healing to try to understand in
quantitative detail how materials design
can be used to control wound healing the
accident we developed was done in my
laboratory by having followed graphics
you can bioengineering what I needed it
was to spin coat a thin layer of ECM
protein on to a glass slide cover up
loaded with silicone rubber put down
harbor
whole surface so that epithelial cells
could appear everywhere chief of staff
themselves gets an impact on Allegra
strips off the PDMS generates a wound
edge that you see over in these images
right here and then she wants us to see
whether the cells will repopulate the
test surface now we're going to show
over on the right hand side of the slide
two movies one for the authentic protein
that has the RGB sequence so it has the
biological information in it and what
protein that's identical except we've
switched the positions of the G and the
D so the physical chemical properties
are identical but the biological
information is gone from the material at
the bottom we're going to go pretty fast
about one hour per second you might be
able to see that there's a counting in
the top left and we'll see how these two
surfaces do we start the real surface
we're at about ten hours you can see
that the rgd surface is healing
relatively rapidly and I'll stop it at
about 20 hours we look down below at
what's happening down here you can see
the t-cells are probing the test surface
but in fact over a 30 hour period the
wound edge really doesn't advance and
all so now by mixing these two proteins
the authentic one and the scrambled on
Eileen can vary the adhesive properties
of the surface and determine how that
changes the zucchini and behavior
as a function of the percentage of the
authentic protein in that service and
what she finds is about a five-fold
increase in the wound healing rate as
the rgv density goes up she showed me
these results and my private unspoken
reaction was well that's not really very
interesting it's not very surprising of
course you put in more of the edesian
with the cells will migrate faster and
the wound will close festival so is
faster enclosure consequence the faster
cell migration it became interesting
when I mean showed me these results no
the migration speed essentially doesn't
change it may change by fifteen percent
but it certainly doesn't change by one
hundred percent as the wound closure
rate does so how can the wound heal
faster if the cells are not migrating
faster well one of the referees very
helpful suggested that perhaps it was
faster cell proliferation we knew that
it wasn't because we watch the thousands
of these movies but in order to satisfy
the referee we watched a thousand more
movies and we determined that the
proliferation rate
it doesn't change so the cells are
moving faster they're not divided
affected how come they're healing faster
it seemed to us that the most likely
source of the faster healing was a
decision in the facility made when they
cross the boundary they test the new
surface if they form encases contacts
and make a decision to move across if
they don't move the pieces contacts they
retreat and so I developed a new
experiment in which she would see code
one protein over top of another to make
an interface where we could look at the
behavior of isolated cells and we could
look at that decision-making process in
a direct way here she just says the RGB
13 / properly RGB protein so you
wouldn't expect to sell us to even know
that that interface is there and if you
watch they don't seem to know they cross
in both directions at equal rates and
they cross rapidly but here she's fun
the adhesive protein over the control
protein watch what happens now in
particular focus on the cells over here
as they approach this interface they
don't cross they bounce off the
interface they run along the interface
but they don't cross at any reasonable
rate see these guys with month-long
bounce off and so by watching many of
these movies I link was able to
determine a crossing problem
awesome rape and when she total
satisfaction of the person RGB in the
test surface we find that the variation
is over a range of six fold and it
accounts essentially entirely for the
variation in the wound healing rate and
so the boundary crossing is the
determinant of the wound healing rate in
these kinds of systems the second story
that I want to tell you about is a story
about analysis of protein synthesis
using non-natural amino acids as probes
rather than as structural components of
macromolecular systems this work was
started as a result of a conversation
with my colleague Eric Schuman and our
biology division Aaron is a
neurobiologist and she's interested in
the role of protein synthesis in the
formation of long-term memory in order
to make long-term memory we have to make
new proteins that's not true for
short-term memory short-term memory is
very fast it doesn't rely on de novo
protein synthesis but long-term memory
does some of that protein synthesis
occurs in taxes rather than occurring in
the cell body when it snaps is
stimulated it turns on a protein
synthesis response and the newly
synthesized proteins will modulate the
synaptic strength so the synapse becomes
either stronger or weaker depending on
the nature of the signal Erin would like
to know what proteins are made in the
snacks and your thoughts to what kinds
of signals this is a very hard
analytical problem first of all the
proteins are made in small numbers you'd
like to see the first ones that get made
and secondly they radiate a suit that
contains thousands of other proteins so
how do you find the new ones when the
old uninteresting ones are there in much
larger numbers situations a little bit
this shown over on left hand side this
is the synapse before this is a synapse
after there's a new protein in this
population but it's hard to find because
essentially all across from the proteins
that we don't care about so we have to
make those proteins invisible and if we
can do that the new protein becomes easy
to find and easy to identify so we make
the old proteins invisible by pulsing
into the cell this is a moment that i
mentioned a few minutes ago if the
approach is related in this event those
13s will pick up visit side chains which
makes those proteins susceptibles in is
about high elevation which allows us to
quicker on a flag tag or biotin some
sort of an affinity tag which then
allows us to purify the newly
synthesized proteins away from all the
old ones which don't have visits in
Denver this is a procedure that we refer
to this work at because nobody wants to
say all that and I'd now like to
emphasize the generality of the method
this allows you to get a type resolved
information on protein synthesis in
cells because you identify only the
proteins made during a pulse of a AJ so
difficult experiment would involve a
seven stimulated
it's full of arms proteins the new
proteins are made in their blue but
because they pee they also carry exist
will then click on the Italian maybe a
biosynthetic will pass anything down
Abaddon palm the newly synthesized
protein so retaining their digested by
oasis and identified sequence by mass
spectrometry this also turned out to be
one of those experiments that worked
better than we had expected an easy way
to show that is an experiment called a
Western blot where we separate the
proteins by electrophoresis under the
action of electric field and then we
transfer them to a membrane we've
clicked on biotin so it end uses
answered by an antibody to visualize
proteins if we put a a chain into the
cells we found hundreds of proteins have
been violated during the energy pulse if
you leave the damage it out we don't see
much background that tells us that we're
not labeling the pre-existing proteins
if we put AJ in protein synthesis we
also such background in those
experiments either so we have to be
making new proteins and we have to have
aaha in the cells when we take this to
mass spectrometry I just like to look at
the numbers overall the right hand side
of the slide in a typical experiment
well I got 700 proteins here
200 and then maybe controlled
experiments were equipment Lee defining
into the medium and here we will pick up
a handful of proteins this tells us what
the level of false positives would be
it's at the level of a few percent now
sometimes you'd like to know not only
what the newly synthesized proteins are
but where they are in the cell and that
can be done in a variant of the
experiment in which we click on a
fluorescent dye rather than a biotin or
a flag tag this experiment was done in
brain slices a much more complex sample
than neuronal cell culture and here we
have a slicer they hit the campus of the
brain the region where memories is going
and we have pulse with AJ and then 54s
stuff you can see lots of protein
lingual in that brain petition here we
go the same thing with pulse in aaj
living with a fluorescent dye but now
we've added protein synthesis in here
and the background is relatively low we
typically get signal to noise in these
experiments of about 15 to 20 so we're
well above background now this
experiment raised another interesting
challenge for us you remember that we
would like to understand neuronal
protein synthesis and neurons are not
the majority cell in the brain there are
ten google sells for every normal second
so there are over filling the role of
protein synthesis you don't want to have
to look through all those unicef protein
you want to restrict labeling to neurons
can you do that not with aaha because aj
is used by the wild-type sense of taste
yourself but if you use an amino acid
that requires as any consensus case you
can express under control of the
neuronal door and Alexis could be used
only by journalists and other selves we
haven't done that yet but we've done an
analogous experiment in bacterial
systems but I think shows proof of
principle and the experiments and ours
are underway so here's experiment that
was done in bacteria where we used to
cut of that Romney as female asset
tagging reagent it's not activated by
the wild-type since it is it is
activated by a meeting federal animals
in the face in fact the same one that we
used 40 phenylalanine a few minutes ago
so they go back to the side that carries
that meets in the dish under control of
a promoter that we can turn on my head i
GTG a sugar animal this will turn the
center taste only when we hang on vtg
and that should be it an operation
fee into bacterial proteins and we
should then be able to turn it on and
off as his wish so I'm going to show you
a timeline at the experiment up here and
a set of wrestling blocks down to you
the first thing that we have to do is to
show because we're looking again for
biotinylated proteins as before we have
to show that we can find the endogenous
or natural biotinylated protein in the
bacterial cell there is one that's right
there so a minus externa before x 0 just
looking at all related proteins that's
what you see then we start the
experiment by adding a final fell down
to the size we look again 15 minutes
later to see if we've seen any labeling
of proteins 15 minutes is a long time in
the life in the bacteria yourself it's a
half a generation the cells has made
thousands of proteins during that
15-minute interval we don't see them we
still receive by James client simulated
protein because there's no newton center
tastes active in the cell we then induce
some precipitation and I'm ttg and we
look again five minutes later and we see
labeling of hundreds of proteins we can
then take time slices to see what
happens in the next five minutes the
next five minutes and then we can
determine the consequences of activation
of a particular promoter in the
bacterial cell in a time-resolved and
sell selective way where does the cell
selectivity come from in this system
well for example if you're interested in
host-pathogen interactions the chemical
warfare that goes on between yourselves
and bacterial pathogens
yourselves you might want to look at
what's happening in the bacterial cells
in terms of 13 synthesis we know as
other bacterial pathogens for example
inject proteins into yourselves to this
evil yourselves agility we'd like to
begin to understand that process without
looking through all the mailing proteins
and what's going on back to the side and
that's we did here we outfitted the
bacterial cells which are the green raj
with the new precipitation you're
interacting romanian selves are shown in
red you're using a conventional cellular
die and then we click on and i'll die
when we find a blind eye those only
after the bacterial cells that gun
allows us to pull out and enrich the
bacterial proteins and identify that
available decision that comes from those
mammalian proteins I mentioned that the
most ambitious implementation of this
experiment would be in whole animals
we're trying to do this now primarily
immediate oats in collaboration and Paul
server who has one of the world's
meeting the aliens laboratories we've
shown that we can label worm proteins
nicely with AJ we're looking here at one
of this ability to that fashion you
might know that well maybe done world's
only eat bacteria and so we into these
months and then by moving up ecoli
sentence with a a check the morgues
either
protein into their own proteins and then
we can label with a press nine so we
know that the words actually we met
surprisingly good label of that C
elegans tissue but we haven't yet
successfully expressed the mutant
synthesis those experiments are underway
to short stories to finish up just a
couple of slides on this one and one
slide this may be a question that only a
polymer chemists would ask what if
proteins were made from the process of
amino acids could they retain their
catalytic and molecular recognition
properties the other properties that we
would like to have for therapeutic one
decimal place from a polymer chemists
point of view proteins are not such
great macromolecules their
proteolytically unstable you can't drive
an alchy camp exposing sister practice
there are a lot of things that we'd like
to change about proteins to use them in
therapy or in industry and we think that
the use of different building blocks
will allow us together now we're
primarily driven here by curiosity we
would really like to know if it is
possible and you might imagine reason
occ because we know that in a single
mutation
cause us to miss pole and the circuit so
what if we try to change channel Jose
away the amino acids building blocks
wanted miss pole and who's going in
those cases is probably will because
proteins involved within the context of
the point anymore so what if we could
wreak evolve them in the laboratory in
new amino acid contexts could we then
restore their function if they've lost
it in the natural sequence we've done
this in a bunch of different systems now
but this is representative of what we
find we started by other the
consequences of chlorination of proteins
you may know that there are about 150
fluoridated pharmaceuticals on the
market fluorine is used to affect the
bioavailability of small molecules we
wonder whether it might be used to
affect the bioavailability of protein
therapeutics as well we also know that
fluorine is in some sense hyper
hydrophobic and that it can be used by
the hydrophobic effect which is
important in determining protein
structure dynamics and function we'd
also shown a few years earlier the
fluorination could be used to stabilize
simple hydrophobic substructures in
proteins like the coiled-coil structure
that's formed from loosing different
peptides leucine zippers and losing
residues at essentially
position along the chain when structures
like that fold into an alpha helix they
put the loo scenes on one face of the
healings that becomes hydrophobic to
protect that surface from water that
changed on rice into this world of
architecture shown here we thought that
if we replace losing with
trifluoroacetic to stabilize that
structure when we look at the circular
dichroism spectra of the leucine and try
for losing forms they were
indistinguishable but when we looked at
the melting mediator we found what they
were all protein unfolded agrees the for
an a in one at 61 and there's no
substitution among the natural amino
acids that removed is melting curve in
this direction leucine is optimized for
this position with respect to the
national but that's a pretty simple
experiment just putting one helix
against another what about a complex
folded protein that might function is an
enzyme like corner chemical a CT of
transcripts we trust this enzyme because
it's kind of a typical one about 200
amino acids long 13 Lucy sites it
functions as a trimer so the active form
of the enzyme has 39 new season
positions we're going to fluoridate as
many of them as we can we never quite
get to one hundred percent that we get
pretty close all of these Stacy
representations here the little blue
balls represent who seemed side chains
so all of those are going to be
fluorinated in the example that i'm
going to tell you about and what we find
is that fluorination does interfere with
protein folding an easy way they show
that is to do a refund
we're in heat up the protein to 60
degrees it loses its natural structure
and unfolds you prove it back down and
you determine how well it regains native
structure if you do that with the
leucine which is going to be the red
bars under our conditions we get about
three-quarters of our initial activity
back it reef olds pretty well the
treasurer losing form in the wild-type
sequence only Renee's about twenty
percent of its activity eighty percent
of the change gets trapped in some
non-productive intermediate structure
because the trifluoromethyl groups are
hydrophobic and sticky in order to try
to move away from that problem to
compensate for that change in properties
we started a laboratory evolution
program where we made thousands of
people's by random mutagenesis and we
look for mutants that performed a little
bit better we found a double mutant in
the first generation where we got about
forty percent of our activity bank we
randomized again we found a third
mutation where we got between fifty and
sixty percent of our activity battery we
randomized again we acquired a fourth
mutation and I have an enzyme that and
in fact
is on the higher than that of the
natural enzyme so this was a
particularly easy example it only
required three rounds of mutagenesis for
mutations to get back to wild-type
behaved and we were very pleased to see
that the molecule didn't dick easy way
out here the easy way out would have
been to eliminate at mussina collapse
and so we would have gotten an active
enzyme but wouldn't have as much fluid
we can't lose any of reducing sites here
and this is a highly fluorinated highly
functional enzyme we've now bunless with
single chain antibodies we've done a
living Brean fluorescent protein and in
fact the results have been in general
consistent with those shown here I think
this is a general strategy for the
engineering of proteins with noble
properties the final story is just one
slide and the example that i'm going to
show you here comes not directly from
our own laboratory but from small
company is amazon which has licensed the
caltech technology and is using
non-canonical amino acids in the
engineering of therapeutic proteins the
first target that they chose was an
engineering form of interferon beta for
the treatment of multiple sclerosis
multiple sclerosis is the most common
neurological disorder among the adults
it affects between two and three million
people it's an autoimmune disease and
eventually results in loss
nation extreme with interferon beta
which is an immune system modulator and
interferon beta helps a lot of people
but it has the same problem that most
therapeutic protein fat it doesn't stay
in the circulation for variable and so
it has to be injected two or three times
a week in some formulations and that
goes i've seen to sean's lack of
compliance people don't want to do it so
they don't do it and the formation of
equalizing and clients I think there's
general agreement that if we could make
interferon-beta stay in the circulation
longer that that would be the preferred
for this strategy for making protein
status circulation longer has been known
for many neighbors is your standard
strategy the attacks are the
polyethylene glycol chain or pay and so
federated therapeutic proteins are
widely known and widely used interferon
example is essentially only reason it's
pegylated form for treatment of
hepatitis C but nobody's been able to
pegylated interferon beta successfully I
think there's no reason no fundamental
reason I couldn't be done it has an
impractical fashion because the
conventional chemistry is
lysine residues and there are just too
many licenses on the surface of a day so
what the others are people did was to
put in a single copy of the zillow homo
alanine and then they used an alcohol of
polyethylene glycol to click on a single
copy of peg and here's what they found
in the early experiments they act a
multiple sclerosis model they looked at
a tumor model because as I said
interferon beta much Lakes the immune
system so it has antitumor activity as
well so here's the experimenter mice and
this was used in large part to persuade
the FDA to beginning a clinical trial
they implant the tumor in mice and then
they watch the increase in the tumor
size as a function of time if there is
no treatment too verbose according to
the green line if the tumor is treated
with a clinical form of interferon beta
three hitters three times meet there's
some suppression of tumor growth but if
its treated with the pegylated
interferon beta 1 unit rather than three
once a week rather than three times a
week there's complete suppression of
tumor growth so as I said those data
were used along with many others to
justify the start of a clinical trial
that's been underway for about a year
now and we'll find out if this approach
has any role in the treatment of
multiple sclerosis I'm sure many of you
who have seen lots of people who have
been able to help mice and never helped
to any human patient that may be welcome
see here we hope not and we hope that
this approach to protein
engineering will in fact enter the
clinic soon so that was the story that I
wanted to tell you I mentioned the names
of a few of my coworkers not nearly
millions kidnap the manager listed here
for the group that worked on the ECM
proteins and it had a chance to talk
about our work of gels I did talk a bit
without protein analysis or debate in
protein evolution work by general player
and roof analysis here we have support
from the usual places or very grateful
to have that again I'd like to thank all
of my posts here for any wonderful honor
we have very warm feelings about
Carnegie Mellon and about Pittsburgh and
it's been a real pleasure to be back
here today thank
I think we have time for a several
questions so actually it's open for
discussion yes
consumer applications
now the question was whether the these
kinds of artificial proteins might be
used as commodity large-scale materials
I think if that happens I think it will
happen a long way down the road i think
that the higher cost applications are
more easily justified i think that what
is novel about this class of materials
is there information content and so i
think its applications in which that
information content is important that
will develop first it may be over time
that larger scale applications come
before
yeah that's that's a serious complaint
the question was when you incorporate
amino acids not natural amino acids the
way I described they'll be incorporated
into all proteins that being made in
itself while about non-natural amino
acids in there does this cause problems
for the help of the cell and do they
complain for example by dying members
that is the phrasing of the question and
the answer has it's often the case is it
depends on how you do the experiment if
you try to replace every copy of a
natural amino acid by not naturally one
then it typically will have a few hours
in which to do that in a bacterial cell
those are doing a material synthesis and
you do it in a batch mode you'll have
three to six maybe even 10 hours where
those cells will continue making
proteins at a high level and eventually
they will begin to shut down because
you've been activated some set of
essential proteins so for synthesis
that's perfectly okay that's the way we
do batch protein expression anyway and
as you saw we can make grand quantities
of these proteins in which we get fairly
high levels of replaces that protein
that I showed on the slide that looked
like only sorry that is a photosensitive
from team that was made in grand
quantities with about fifty percent
replacement of the fennel Valley High
this is a feat now the proteomics
experiment is quite different they were
not trying to replace many copies
people asking in fact we do single hip
statistics on the proteins we even
replace long cotton or none because we
only need one cycle conjugations in
order to enrich that protein from mixed
and so in that case we see very little
perturbation of the cellular physiology
as you can imagine this is a very modest
change in the freaking truck instead of
a methyl group of finding reincorporated
is in at one site in the protein and so
this actually shows very little evidence
of change in cellular physiology now
that's not to say that we don't worry
about we worry about a lot and the new
boxes controlled experiments to see if
there's evidence that we've changed the
protein synthesis program of yourself
but in general there's not much evidence
for underseas of hip condition I'm
wondering for the repertoire oysters
that you develop are you
yeah so the question was are we up
against the fundamental limitation in
terms of the ability of the protein to
fold and maybe you're asking are there
some amino acids that maybe would never
allow us to hold the protein properly
and we don't think about this a very
sophisticated way my intuition is that
this will be largely size-dependent that
as we increase the size of the amino
acid side chain further and further from
the natural amino acids will have
increasing difficulty on the other hand
I did the street evolution a strategy
will prove to be a very general strategy
for compensation even for relatively
large spirit changes in amino acid side
chains you'll notice that for the
fluoridation in case which dozens of all
hold the change in size and the change
in polarity and a change of the nature
of water at the surface then it require
only three rounds of evolution and open
for compensating mutations to compensate
for thirteen trifluoromethyl toys so in
general the evolution program has turned
out to be very efficient than
compensating we'll see whether there are
some things that he can come say and one
thing i should say we did see in the gfp
experienced that the florida
side chains disappeared quickly from two
positions of gfp there are my team
losing psychosis gfp two of them appear
perhaps not to be permissive with
respect to fluorination so we must live
scenes there but we retained losing's at
the other sites and in fact we gained
back new routines at other sites so we
weren't driving the leucine out of the
protein but we did perhaps drive and out
of two positions is
yeah the question was what about a
vacation therapeutic proteins since
they're being made in cells how readily
can they be purified and i would say
that i'm not an expert in that sort of
protein purification and what I've
learned I'd largely learned through our
collaborations with the company Allison
where they had to do that purification
in order to satisfy the FDA and start
putting this into human patients I what
I could say is that they're going to a
few to be substantial new difficulties
that come about by virtue of having
corporated the non-canonical amino acids
it is an expensive process I think the
purification process probably in all six
or eight steps various kinds of
selective precipitations and columns and
so on but it doesn't seem to be any
harder than this wreck invention
yeah that there was a very nice question
things but there is an alternative way
to do the chemistry of non-national
relaxes which involves the incorporation
of a single copy of the non-canonical at
one site in the protein that's generally
done by using a stop codon to deliver
the non-natural amino acid and then a
suppressor T RNA as the carrier or the
amino acids so I would say that the new
methods are complementary is one of them
if you'd like to label a protein at a
single site for the study of life's a
fluorescence something like that then
perhaps talks about the new amino acid
one cycle our interest is primarily of
making proteins that have no function
and there i think the incorporation of
multiple copies gets to malfunction
festive proteins are fundamentally made
by incorporating multiple copies of
their amino acids and so we regard this
as an evolution process that's more
nearly parallel to the natural evolution
of protest also in the cases of
proteomics too because we don't know
what we're looking forward we can't use
the nonsense suppression approach we
just have to pulse in the Pro and then
look for whatever it was
hey so i'm going to say for labeling
experiments the other approach is better
for some of these other things the
global corporations
yeah questions what about targeting of
that area again I think we're doing
anything unusual there's no targeting of
interferon specifically to the tumor the
pegylation just keeps the molecule in
the circulation law firm in fact it
appears to stay in circulation for
several weeks but there is no specific
partner either for conventional or
permanently yeah I remember that many
years ago we discussed with Dave can we
go also to know monday no that's a
larger than scale applications and we
started discussing that usually we have
a Teflon cupboard Franklin to do eggs
but can we at fluorinated protein and
make acts on any kind of attack right so
I'm not sure however you would test that
it's a self of course obvious question
but I'm thinking about some other not
necessarily biomedical applications
which is obviously the first thing do
you think that some conductive polymers
or some is special other things can it
be also at light in a smaller maybe
surface modification wanted yeah I think
so no I think that it will learn from
them to fashion costs and if the
application demands that Boston that
there's no fundamental promising
candidate
sale so I think even for things like
specialty elastomers the cost could be
justified I think that as components of
composite materials were perhaps the
ultimate material is something else that
the protein services organize that other
material I think those kinds of
applications will probably be America's
less hope that will happen and that's
think they forget
and let me close this by saying that for
the record guy buries attention to that
waiver one second during that entire
presentation and I was watching no
wonder David won the ashkan award he
richly deserved it as he does Dixon
prize join us on the fourth court and
thank enjoy me thinking David Tyrell one
more time for his part